Well, okay.
I got this.
I got, oh, no.
[NOISE]
>> Hey, whatcha doing there?
>> I'm building an awesome new app and
it's using a ton of
cool libraries I found.
>> Oh, your libraries are in
these Java archives here?
>> What? No. These are just jars.
Anyway, a bunch of the libraries
I'm using are themselves using
even more libraries.
>> Which gives you even
more jars to juggle, right?
>> What do my jars have
to do with anything?
I'm making jam later.
Anyway, I checked all my jars
into source control, but
now it takes forever for
me to check anything out.
And anytime one of my libraries updates,
it's just a giant pain to sort out.
>> You know that Gradle can take care
of this whole problem for you, right?
>> Well, Gradle can do just
about everything, can't it?
>> It's true.
Gradle makes using external
dependencies super simple.
It can take care of downloading
your dependencies from repositories
either hosted by your organization or
publicly available out on the internet.
It can also handle your
trends div dependencies.
That is the dependencies
of your dependencies.
It even makes sure that if you're using
the same dependency across multiple
projects you'll only ever
download dependency once.
No more juggling jars.
>> Hey Mark, you want any jam?